>> Sean: SAD DAY TODAY FOR OUR
FOX NEWS FAMILY AND FRANKLY, THE
COUNTRY, BECAUSE HE WAS A TRUE
PATRIOT.
OUR COLLEAGUE, FRIEND, THE
BRILLIANT CHARLES KRAUTHAMMER
PASSED AWAY TODAY AT THE AGE OF
68, FREQUENT GUEST ON THE
PROGRAM OVER THE YEARS.
I PICKED THIS CODE BECAUSE IT
BECAME, FOR HIM, A WAY FOR
HIM TO CONSTANTLY MAKE FUN OF ME
AND IT WAS A REAL KIND OF
SPECIAL MOMENT BETWEEN US I WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, I LOVE
THE FACT THAT YOU GAVE A SPEECH
ONE DAY AND YOU TOLD A STORY
ABOUT ME AND ALL THE YEARS WE
HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER.
GO AHEAD.
YOU CAN MOCK ME ON NATIONAL TV.
>> I AM ALWAYS SURPRISED THAT
YOU ARE UPSET BY THAT.
IT'S THE MOST CHARMING STORY.
AS YOU KNOW, I TOLD YOU AGAIN ON
A SPECIAL THAT BRET BAIER DID,
HE PROMPTED ME, HE WAS SORT OF
THE PROVOCATEUR THERE.
I SAID, SEAN DOESN'T REALLY LIKE
IT BUT IT'S A WONDERFUL STORY.
IT JUST SHOWS, I LIKE IT BECAUSE
IT SHOWS HOW I HAVEN'T MADE
BEING IN A WHEELCHAIR THE CENTER
OF MY LIFE AND THE FACT THAT YOU
EVEN WEREN'T AWARE OF IT I
THOUGHT WAS LOVELY.
IT WAS A WAY TO COMPLIMENT YOU.
>> Sean: LISTEN, LISTEN, IT'S
A FRIENDLY STORY THAT WE HAVE
BETWEEN THE TWO OF US, BUT THE
STORY IS REALLY INSPIRING.
THE SPECIAL WAS FANTASTIC, BY
THE WAY, AND IT REMINDS ALL OF
US I THINK WE HAVE PROBLEMS
SOMETIMES, EVERYBODY HAS
PROBLEMS AND SOME PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING WITH SOME OF THE
INCREDIBLE THINGS IN YOUR
ABILITY TO OVERCOME, I FOUND
INSPIRING.
SO THANK YOU.
SPEAK TO HIS WHOLE LIFE WAS A
PROFILE IN COURAGE.
HIS WHOLE LIFE.
HE HAD A BRILLIANT INTELLECT.
HE WAS A PATRIOT.
HE LOVED THIS COUNTRY.
HE FOUGHT HARD TO MAKE THIS A